дуже важливо щоби такі чутливі закони як
закон про е мобілізацію як закон про
електронний реєстр обговорювався
публічно ми звертаємося до голови
профільного комітету з питань свободи
слова з наступним колеги потрібно
повертати журналістів в сесійну залу
потрібно повернати трансляцію включати
виключені телеканали марафон треба
навпаки припиняти і негайно провести
спільне засідання антикорупційного
комітету і свободи слова з тим що що
відбувається з каналом рада 250 млн за
два роки війни на розробку а якогось там
контенту Та в нас Олексій ганчаренко
безкоштовно розробив контент і в
тіктокіі показує трансляції Верховної
Ради розумієте А ви просто витрачаєте
дурно кошти платників податків